It's great to welcome to the program today,
Charles Wheelan, who is professor of public
policy at Dartmouth, author of a number of
books, many of which I've read, including
a Naked Economics, Naked Money, Naked Statistics.
Great to have you on today.
Great. I'm glad you've read all the naked
books that we reported to this series.
So you taught well in the book. You talk a
lot, particularly in naked economics and naked
money, about the impact and repercussions
at a macroeconomic level of the government
doing things which include making adjustments
to the money supply, making money available
in different ways. So maybe to pick something
that's going on now when you look at the so-called
coronavirus stimulus and how that was administered
partially to individuals, partially as loans,
partially to corporations, what about it from
a broad economic standpoint was done correctly
and what was not so good?
I think the best thing is that it put money
in the pockets of people who needed it, small
businesses. And we'll get to how well it was
targeted because that anticipates, I think,
one of the weaknesses and also consumers who
are at risk of missing rent payments, being
evicted and the like. One of the most intriguing
concepts in economics is the paradox of thrift.
This idea that when something bad happens
are natural and entirely rational. Response
is to spend less, to hang on to what we have.
And of course, as soon as we hang on to what
we have, then we don't buy our refrigerator,
don't buy a car, don't go out to dinner. And
that's the income of all of those folks. They
hang on more tightly. And of course, more
businesses are in distress to somehow government
needs to overcome that paradox of thrift,
not in the financial crisis. The problem was
that all our financial institutions were paralyzed.
Nobody could get credit. If you want to go
to a restaurant, the restaurant was open.
But, you know, how can we open the spigots
of credit again? So the economy worked with
covid. We've got an entirely different problem.
The banking system is mercifully healthy and
many people went into covid in pretty good
financial shape, but they couldn't spend the
money they had because the restaurant was
closed. So the challenge there was to keep
those restaurants afloat until we could get
through. And I guess we're now seeing the
end of the tunnel, the pandemic, just keep
them afloat as opposed to starting up, say,
the financial system again.
Yeah, it seems when I look at the way some
European countries and other countries handled
this, they were more aggressive with the idea
of we will pay the salaries of your employees
so that you don't lay anybody off. I think
the idea being that there would be less friction
in getting things back up to speed because
the the employees would still be employees
and so on. Do you think that that was not
done well enough in the US?
I think our approach was probably a little
more scattershot. Some of the payments to
businesses had the effect of keeping employees
on the books. On the other end, I talked to
small business people who faced a dilemma
whereby if they were kept on at reduced salary,
their employees might have done better if
they went on unemployment. Right. And so you
created some kind of tension there. And then
obviously what we've been reading in the news
in the last couple of weeks, about a high
proportion of these payments going to a small
number of firms. I haven't delved into that.
But that does get to a question you always
have to face, which is how well targeted is
this to the folks who really need support
in the near term? That's priority number one.
Priority number two is how well targeted is
it to the folks who will continue to spend
in ways that keep other businesses healthy?
And what what are the answers to those three
questions that so many of you know, it strikes
me as given the time allotted, that it was
probably about a B plus. OK, you know, we
forget that nobody was. Well, it's not true.
Nobody was planning for this, but it certainly
wasn't what we expected to come along. And
when you've got to draw up something like
this so quickly and deal with the politics,
get it through a very divided Congress, I
think we did actually reasonably well up to
the present. We're now, again, we're arguing
over what the next phase of it ought to be.
Yeah, I mean, I think that we can talk about
the lack of pandemic response readiness by
the administration on the more medical side,
getting rid of the pandemic response team,
ignoring the playbook, et cetera. But the
shock to the system from the economic side
would have been a shock. Regardless, it sounds
like, is what you're saying.
I think that's true. And I think there's some
things that seem superficially attractive
that have some downsides. So, for example,
the moratorium on evictions and moratorium,
I think it makes perfect sense that you do
not want to be throwing people out on the
street in the middle of a pandemic. On the
other hand, you do have to appreciate that
those folks who are not paying rent are not
paying rent to other small property owners
who will then have trouble. So, you know,
I'm much more comfortable with something that
substitutes for those rent. Payments, right?
There's no eviction and therefore keeps the
property owners whole as opposed to just throwing
the thrust of the pain on these small renters,
many of whom have just a couple of apartments
that are a source of revenue. And if we say
you can't evict them, but they're not paying
your rent, then you've just created a different
level of distress.
There is a perspective in economic thinking.
Any time you're talking about giving people
money, this applies to stimulus. This applies
to programs like universal basic income. This
applies to minimum wage increases. And the
very general idea is you devalue the currency
when you when you make it easier to get money,
when you increase the supply of money, simple
supply and demand suggests each dollar becomes
worth less. There is inflation and you end
up basically in the exact same place. Can
you talk now about the additional knowledge
we have, including from behavioral economics
and other types of economic thinking that
that makes that less cut and dry?
Well, the one great puzzle of our time, Prie
covid, is why we're not seeing more inflation.
We have pumped going back to the financial
crisis, up to and including the covid response,
we have pumped just staggering amounts of
money and liquidity into the pipes and we're
barely reaching our inflation target targets
and sometimes failing to reach our inflation
target. So if you went back to grad school
when I was in grad school in the early 90s
at the University of Chicago and said, hey,
let me give you a hypothetical experiment
where we pump trillions of dollars into the
economy, do you think you're going to get
price increases or maybe even a little deflation?
Everybody would have said that is impossible.
We're still trying to kind of work through
that part of the behavioral economics explanation.
And just let me say parenthetically, I think
behavioral econ is one of the most interesting
and exciting things to come along because
it helps to answer some of these questions
is that when you become conditioned to stable
prices for a long period of time, then it's
harder to raise prices. It's the flip side
of the 70s when everyone just assumed, hey,
we're going to raise, but I don't care what's
going on. The macro, my prices are going up
15 percent this year just because that's what
you do in spring. You know, maybe we're seeing
the back side of that. There's some discussion
about whether globalization has just continued
to increase the global supply so much that
we can absorb the money and and spend it around
the world. And the competition from China
and Vietnam keeps prices low because American
firms can't raise prices. It just keeps that
constant pressure. My colleague here, Danny
Blanchflower, has argued that a lot of the
labor market data are very misleading. Unemployment
looks really low. But when you delve into
it, a lot of folks are not working as many
hours as they would like to. They're feeling
more tenuously attached to the labor market.
And then he's found this interesting thing
where if you ask people how likely they are
to be fired. Or lose their job, they overstate
it by like five fold, you know, because you
can then follow them and find out how many
of them are actually fired. What that means
is that they are very reticent to ask for
more money because they feel that their job
is more precarious than it actually is. And
that is another thing, keeping prices low.
So it's probably some combination of these
things. But I suspect that if you come up
with some unifying theory of why all this
money flowing into the system hasn't led to
more inflation, you will certainly be on the
Nobel short list.
Well, on the other side of this example that
we're seeing in, I think in both naked economics
and money, although you'll you'll correct
me, you often use my birth country of Argentina
as an example of disasters when it comes to
currency. I mean, we've we had, you know,
the peg, the dollar peso peg, which completely
failed hyperinflation, not at the level of
of like Zimbabwe or Venezuela, but but still
pretty bad. All these terrible situations
when it comes to currency, what seems to be
the tipping point where those cascading currency
disasters happen in countries?
I think the difference between Argentina and
most places in the world is that there's just
not a lot of credibility. People don't believe
the central bank. They don't believe the fiscal
authorities. And a lot of monetary policy
is about credible commitment that you say
you're going to do something, you do it. The
markets respond in ways that if they believe
you reinforce what's going to happen. So when
the chair of the Fed in the United States
says we're serious about inflation, we're
not going to let prices rise faster than two
percent ever, well, then people don't raise
their prices because they assume that the
Fed would fight that back. And it becomes
a self reinforcing prophecy when the monetary
authorities in Argentina say, hey, we're going
to fight inflation. What everybody's done
laughing. They say, yeah, we've seen this
movie 11 times before. I I mean, it's been
a long time since I wrote Naked Money. We
were going to put a whole chapter on Argentina
and instead we just used a lot of examples.
Yeah. That I'm glad you didn't do the whole
chapter. That would have been that would have
been more devastating. So so when it comes
to in naked money, when you talk about the
credibility of money, as you're kind of talking
about in the context of Argentina, you do
address cryptocurrency and you and you take
head on some of the bullet points that we
hear from some of the anti cryptocurrency
people, such as it doesn't have inherent value.
And you explain that, you know, the idea of
gold having inherent value is also less clear
maybe than some people point out. What's your
sense now? Since the book was written about
cryptocurrency, we've seen, you know, early
in the pandemic, people expecting Bitcoin
to go crazy, were disappointed that it didn't.
But then in the last few months, we've actually
seen significant increase in the value of
Bitcoin. What's your sense of it now?
I'm still not very sold on the idea that Bitcoin
is here for the long run. A number of reasons
to be part of. You expect money to do a number
of things, and I don't think Bitcoin does
any of them very well. So one is as a unit
of exchange and this is the easiest one where
it's clearly failed me. Part of the reason
that we use dollars and not Argentine pesos
is we have a pretty good idea of what the
dollar is going to be worth next year, even
ten years, maybe plus or minus two percent.
But it really doesn't move a whole lot. Yeah,
with Bitcoin, right. When people say, wow,
Bitcoin is on awards up four hundred percent,
that's not a good thing from the standpoint
of money. Now, if you invested in it, you
made a lot of money. But the point of money
is I'm going to buy a house and I'm going
to say, you know, David, I'm going to give
you one hundred bitcoins a year for the next
30 years. That's the way a mortgage works.
Now, if those bitcoins go up four hundred
percent in value, my mortgage payment just
went up four percent. So it's very hard for
us to contract using a monetary, you know,
that's flexible. But even if it's going up,
you just want something stable, that the other
things that we look for are is it a good store
of value? That one, I think, is also uncertain.
Yes, it's gain value, but it's also plummeted
at times on that one.
Charles, after how many years of of at least
it retaining some value, would we be able
to say that the store of value requirement
is met?
I don't know if it's a number of years. I
think it's the the percentage of people who
are persuaded that it will hold its value.
I mean, because as you correctly pointed out,
it's all whether I believe that it has value.
And if I do, then I'll use it. So certainly
more than it used to. Yeah. And then the last
one is kind of as a unit of account or not
as kind of but as a medium of exchange. So
how easy is it to do transactions. And it's
still much easier for me to use a credit card
or use cash than it is for Bitcoin. I've got
to go buy the bitcoins and so that.
I guess let me push back slightly on that
one in in the last year, I mean, now, just
like my credit cards linked up with my phone
and I can swipe it, I can link Bitcoin with
my phone with instant dollar conversions and
swipe at the same. So it's definitely changed.
A lot of progress has been made. And I would
say, you know, if you're in a place like Venezuela
or you're in a place where everything is just
crumbling around you, then Bitcoin might serve
some of these purposes better than for me
sitting here in New Hampshire. Right. You've
got to park wealth someplace. You got to move
it out of the country quickly. So it certainly
has a purpose. Now, I'll add one other caveat.
That may be my biggest concern, which is at
present, it's Bitcoin is a really handy medium
of exchange for people doing really nefarious
things. So we just had a huge hack of a hospital
system in Vermont, one of these ransomware
things where it's, you know, pay us X millions
of dollars or we'll destroy all your systems.
And of course, the payment they want is in
Bitcoin, which is terrific for them. You know,
I do have some concerns from the Bitcoin standpoint
about if this becomes the medium of exchange
for people doing bad things, then there might
be some regulatory crackdown on it, in which
case it becomes less attractive as a currency
for everybody else.
Yeah, that's interesting. I mean, I, I for
me, the biggest concerns remain in many cases,
transaction fees and the unpredictable value
that it's used for crime stuff. I mean, when
Silk Road was shut down, which was believed
to be a huge piece of the Bitcoin market,
the Bitcoin market barely was affected. A
number of transactions or volume. It seemed
to be a much smaller piece of it. And also,
by the way, I mean, most crimes are being
committed involving dollars. Most racketeering
is happening. And also that one is not super
strong for me. But the logistics of of it
and the volatility seem to be my biggest concerns.
I don't know.
Yeah. And, you know, I think bubbles are interesting.
You never know for sure if you're in a bubble
until it's over. So in twenty five, I thought
the property prices were frothy. Yeah. But
I didn't short the property market. It would
have been kind of hard to do. I also thought
that Amazon was wildly overpriced. I was right
on one of those things and terribly wrong
on the other. So I think time will tell. But
I love the discussion because I think Bitcoin
forces us to think about what money is. What
are the pieces of paper issued by the Argentine
government different than the pieces of paper
issued by the American company? Because it's
all just paper.
Thinking about the next five years, 10 years,
what types of systemic changes do you anticipate
to economic and financial systems that are
a result of either technological change or
cultural change, like the big picture things?
I think the biggest question is what the next
phase of capitalism looks like. We're not
going to go socialist. You know, I'm old enough
to have lived through the Soviet Union. I
traveled there. I've been to Cuba. That's
not the future. On the other hand, I think
I teach a lot of young people who look around
and say, well, something's not quite right.
I mean, why is the richest country in the
history of civilization? Why are people living
on the streets? Clearly what the populace
of both the left and the right, both Trump
and Bernie, who when you pass it, are saying
some of the same things, different policy,
but same similar rhetoric. Yeah, right. So
exactly. Not the diagnosis is broadly similar.
They are reflecting the fact that despite
great wealth in over my lifetime, enormous
growth in the economy and incomes, people
feel very insecure and they feel not fully
happy with the level of disruption. And of
course, we're looking at AEI and other things
coming down the pike. So I think the question
for people who are center, right and center
left, so not the socialist, not the nationalist
populist is how do we tighten the safety net
so that the folks who we know are being disrupted
or will be disrupted can kind of bounce back
into this vibrant, growing economy without
just hitting the ground. And interestingly,
I think center left is always talked about
this. When you look at the Scandinavian countries,
they're they're actually robust capitalist
economies. Yes. They just have a tighter safety
net. Right. But I think it's going to become
more interesting for center right there. Folks
like Oren Cass, who's a conservative thinker,
who's talking more about the role that unions
might play from a conservative standpoint
to give workers more voice. I think there's
going to be a lot of fresh thinking about
how we harness everything that is great about
capitalism. And there's a lot there while
we so the holes that are clearly the failures
and deficiencies or in case I'll have to I'll
have to do a little reading up.
Hey, before I let you go, I recently read
the book station Eleven by Emily St. John
Mandel, which is Pandemic Literature and also
beautiful writing. Absolutely fantastic book.
Fantastic book. You've written the rationing
also about a global pandemic. This is like
a genre now, pandemic literature.
Lawrence Wright is another terrific writer,
wrote a book. I think the end of October was
about a pandemic. So, yes, my book, The Rationing,
is about who gets the vaccine right during
a pandemic. And just to point out, it was
written in twenty nineteen. Yes. So, yes,
it is a you know, part of the reason this
genre is the same reason that apocalypse movies
are a Shandra is we're fascinated by how we
behave as humans in adverse circumstances
where we watch war movies over and over again.
So it wasn't that I was a genius about the
pandemic. That was just a convenient tool
for looking at the political response. It's
really a political thriller.
That's the rationing. We've been speaking
with Charles Wheelan, professor of public
policy at Dartmouth.
Also, check out the naked books, Naked Economics,
Naked Money, Naked Statistics. I so appreciate
your time today. I was great to talk to you.